mais je voudrais moi poser le sujet de
manière politique et puis dire ensuite
la technique qui se trouve dans ces
amendements il faut quand même qu'on ait
conscience que dans certains territoires
la flambée des locations saisonnières
est en train de totalement déstabiliser
l'offre de l'habitat il faut que l'on
ait conscience que l'on renvoie monsieur
le ministre de commission en Conseil
national de la refondation et maintenant
en mission parlementaire des décisions
j'ai bien compris que les mesures
fiscales ne suffisaient pas et ne
permettit pas tout mais les mesures
fiscales sont aussi des symboles qu'on
envoie des populations qui n'en peuvent
plus qui voient les jeunes être logés de
plus en plus loin des zones émidemment
touristiques qui voit la structure de
l'habitat des cités touristiques se
transformer complètement qui voit la
structure commerçante se transformer
complètement donc moi j'ai proposé trois
amendements qui réduisent
l'abattement fiscal de 71 %. un
abattement que le Sénat avait est
déclaré exorbitant voilà un an je veux
aussi supprimer un effet d'obè
aujourd'hui il est beaucoup plus
intéressant pour un propriétaire de
louer en location saisonnière cela
rapporte beaucoup plus et on a beaucoup
moins de difficultés et la fiscalité est
beaucoup plus faible il faut être un
vrai se laïque sur certains territoires
aujourd'hui pour faire de la location à
l'année résultat beaucoup de
propriétaires passent de la location à
l'année en location saisonnaire il y a
une véritable évaporation
et une tension de plus en plus grande
sur le marché de l'immobilier et sur le
une raréfaction foncière qui devient
très préoccupante voilà pourquoi les
élus de territoire comme lumière le
territoire du Pays-Basque unanime
demandent qu'on mette fin à cette niche
fiscale qui est de plus en plus
difficile à supporter
merci